encuentra la ecuación de la recta
perpendicular a esta recta que pasa por
el punto 2 y 8 entonces la primera parte
de la información nos dice que es
perpendicular a la recta que tenemos
aquí qué significa eso bueno si es
perpendicular a esta recta su pendiente
tiene que ser la inversa negativa de dos
quintos si la pendiente de esta recta es
menos dos quintos la ecuación de la
recta que tenemos que encontrar que es
perpendicular tiene una pendiente
inversa así que en lugar de dos quintos
va a ser cinco medios y en lugar de ser
negativa va a ser positiva de modo que
este es el inverso negativo de menos dos
quintos de acuerdo tomamos el signo
negativo y lo cambiamos a positivo
intercambiamos el 5 y el 2 y obtenemos 5
medios entonces esta tiene que ser
nuestra pendiente y podemos usar la
forma punto pendiente ya que pasa por
este punto que tenemos aquí
así que usemos la forma punto pendiente
que menos este valor de ya que tiene que
estar en la recta es igual a nuestra
pendiente 5 medios por x menos este
valor de x el valor de x cuando ya es
igual a 8
esta es la ecuación de la recta en la
forma punto pendiente si queremos
ponerla en la forma pendiente
intersección tenemos que hacer un poco
de álgebra de manipulación de algebraica
que menos 8 es igual a déjenme
distribuir los cinco medios entonces
cinco medios de x menos cinco medios por
dos es igual a cinco luego sumamos ocho
de los dos lados y nos queda que es
igual a cinco medios de x sumamos ocho a
menos cinco y el resultado es más 3
y terminamos hasta el próximo vídeo